[Music]
there's one thing that every eSports fan
can appreciate the comeback there's
nothing quite like it the incredible
skill the impossible odds and the sheer
unadulterated hype but not all comebacks
are created equal which is why we
decided to count down the top 10 taking
into account how hard the comeback was
how much it mattered in the grand scheme
of the tournament and how crazy it was
to watch so sit back relax and get those
buybacks ready because we are counting
down the top 10 comebacks in the history
of eSports in eSports there are a few
moments that transcend games change them
and define them but there are even fewer
that are as influential and iconic as
Evo moment 37 and it's coming in at
number 10 on our list in the Street
Fighter 3 losers finals at Evo 2004
Daigo Umehara met Justin Wong in a match
everyone was waiting for and it was
there with his back against the wall
that Daigo pulled off one of the
greatest comebacks ever and made his
mark in history
[Applause]
Daigo did the impossible defying the
odds with just a pixel of health the
play stands as an incredible display of
skill and ability to act under pressure
producing one of the first eSports
moments to truly go viral
number nine is one of early league of
legends as most incredible plays vx
peckin in the group stage at IEM
katowice 2013 fans were treated to a
matchup of Europe's best SK gaming vs.
fnatic in all kinds of trouble toffee
candy panda red buff on it and it's not
going to escape that one it turns out
very very nicely for SK gaming there as
the game went on the teams traded blows
but eventually SK capitalized off of a
pivotal teamfight and looked to close
out the game
thank you
they thought it was all over turns out
they were right I'm just gonna pile
straight up towards those super minions
in the face you can see there's good in
that case definitely I'll put the Nexus
he's trying to do the people in the beta
starts trying to defend them interface
he's trying to take the necessary
[Applause]
expec it took the game into his own
hands and made the decision to backdoor
that decision single-handedly one
fanatic the game and turned expec a into
a star our number eight entry comes from
a classic matchup between two of
Tekken's best and it doesn't get much
closer than this JDC our and neuroma are
two of the best Tekken players in the
world but you wouldn't have known it
looking at the life bars during their
match at the 2018 Tekken World Tour
Finals neuroma was ready to take the
round but JD CR had something else
planned for him everyone has said it you
got to be on point but when I Austin
about jacket on or who she was gonna use
he didn't feel really confident we're
talking of you is thinking pretty hard
on who should I use so it doesn't really
surprise me now they run with Hitachi
but big combo coming in from the robot
oh here we go he has them in the ready
potential perfect here yep I think it's
gonna get it oh he's bought Oh nobody
dropped in there you definitely won the
extra Dempsey went to the cockpit unable
to get up with a big demon uppercut the
follow-up yeah looking towards the wall
as well all but just shorts
[Music]
three routes straight versus the robot
is just a Oh je dis yah
would you like to be here maybe here a
second I hope he lied to you coming in
at number 7 on our list is one of the
greatest comebacks in Call of Duty
history a moment cod fans call the full
sale come back at the MLG fall
Invitational in 2013 tournament
favorites complexity and fan favorite
optic gaming faced off in the grand
finals with a map and match point on the
line it looked as if made and the boys
were cruising to an easy win to extend
the series but complexity had other
plans in mind complexity finally opened
up around with first blood first blood
goes to complexity I think this is gonna
be their first round one I seen crazier
things happen I don't doubt somebody
could clutch this one on three I doubt
it but I love your optimism
let's see if we can do it already get in
tag now getting pin
complexity they're not going down
without a fight
shots from above from aches will answer
back and it's now 2 - clay stirrer picks
off Jacob things are going bad for optic
and nadeshot now a one on three
situation man up straight push there
from complexity he is gonna be fall down
catch they chatted all it transitioned
one more player can come getting the one
up 306 with the one on three clutch
complexities bay life here on express
surgeon straight round after round
they clutch to those when it was all
said and done complexity came back from
an o-5 deficit to win the match
six five pickup it is all up to each
other one on three I think very tough
but they were up by five and they are
your MLG ball Invitational champion
that's right they won six straight
rounds to close out the tournament our
number six entry is MK Leo's incredible
run to become the first ever Evo smash
ultimate champion Leo ran a near-perfect
loser's bracket gauntlet to make it all
the way back to the grand finals but his
opponent tweaked had him on the ropes
man it's definitely transcended right
now in Charizard out just throw out the
flare blitz and in this Bank take all of
our souls right now
- to tweet one more game
but that didn't faze em Kaleo one bit so
many air dodges
yes to play so reactive yeah there it is
again leo says hail to the king baby
we're going to Game four this could go
either way he is not falling for that
falling down off stage there is the
reset layout is just on top of him all
over the place and it's so unfortunate
to tweak because this tournament could
have been over Leo won three straight
games to reset the bracket and then he
did it again waiting with a third jab so
smart he's gonna try to go low Jimmy
spiked it he missed a layup be quick to
be here 2019 Evo champion Leo edged his
name into history with one of the most
incredible comebacks and smash and
claimed the ultimate prize coming in at
number five is cloud nines legendary win
at the Boston elite major the tournament
started off badly cloud 9 dropped their
first two games in the new legend stage
but they rallied dropping only a single
map on their way to the Grand Finals
where they met tournament favorites faze
clan absolutes going away and decipher
dance Guardian automatic on his own
running up the short position I think
one of my sis heard him which means that
they can all hold angles that's both
great the flash fake one workout face
class take the first map of this series
Eric
[Music]
[Applause]
with that series tied at one apiece
phase pushed cloud9 - match point on the
deciding map but it was there that the
North Americans clawed back forcing
double overtime before making their mark
on csgo history make the point just by
staying
[Applause]
laughing do you know what that noise
means that it means it's batch point
cloud nine so from this position before
you cannot miss a single shot Guardian
waits patiently as cloud my scepter push
up
[Applause]
it was a miraculous win in true David
versus Goliath fashion this major
victory was one that no one saw coming
in 2018 oh gee shook the dota world with
a TI championship that defied all odds
and the fairy tale finals that got them
there is number four on our list let us
paint you a picture oh gee were down one
to two in the series LGD were on match
point
our heroes had their backs against the
wall yes this is a rough situation to be
in
of course but we're gonna overcome it
together you know we know we're one game
away it doesn't matter we're gonna go
ahead and have fun when the next one and
window one after we're getting tested
embrace it
yes and in the deciding game for LGD
looked like they were about to run away
with the match in dominant fashion
Thompson being chased by something
mystical the dust down tops it as well x
Nova picked up inside of the sample
Thompson won't fall they'll find out it
- can they get severs well Jax is there
at the side but he does not have
relocate available there's no safe who
said and effectively at the end of the
day I pulled see you wipe there by PSC
LGD but sev have something else in mind
look at the cool control Swami has he
got it are they getting set up by the
court somebody never wait for a diver
dr. bleep Sid you can stay over there
point where the snowball sir
sodas will be edified the iron for them
fully load you need that so there's
never two minutes they get to total
never do in Saudi Anna Anna can you do
it in chat all [ __ ]
of his lifetime astonishingly that
single play was enough for OG to tie the
series
by and in game 5 they completed the most
miraculous run in TI history number
three on our list is one of eSports his
most iconic plays and comebacks in the
2016 MLG Columbus major semi finals
luminosity were on the edge of defeat
with a 15-9 score line but it was there
that cold Zahra made an impossible play
to kick-start an equally impossible
comeback yeah there's a lot of pressure
on him he's gotta hit these shots we saw
holding this in his spot before the same
spot but but with much more utility to
work with here it comes once again the
first base is that trainees gonna hit
the ground there's cold
call the same luminosity with your play
unthinkable scenes there on the B
apartments they need a huge play without
something I'm never gonna see ever again
luminosity shut liquid out after that
round to take the map one versus three
this is for everything this is for the
map right now eco making its way around
the smoke it was found Abel's for taco
but that's in luminosity with a comeback
from 1510 an amazing play from coal with
the AWP all the way back into our time
into a victory ten rounds in a row for a
luminosity fifty nine to nineteen
fifteen I have no idea how they managed
to pull that off what's crazy is they
did the same on map - with liquid on
match point yet again this time putting
an end to the MA dream eco needs a big
big play to save his team in this round
and he's got a guy going towards
headshot it's fur the spray comes in the
flames are making it difficult but what
can he go - he's got an Phenix jumping
through the smoke and stood Renly's a
one versus poor retake with an AWP and
there it is Cole's going to take his
head off and luminosity will find
themself in the grand finals against
Navi oh yeah and the Brazilians also
went on to win the major taking the
runner-up spot on our list is a game
that has become synonymous with the word
come back that's right we're talking
about CLG EU vs. Moscow 5 in the group
stage of Dreamhack summer 2012 despite
the early game going CLG II used way the
mid game was all Moscow 5 who took
multiple objectives and found themselves
with a gold lead in excess of 20,000 Wow
Moscow 5 really tons of pressure it this
is what we say so many times but Moscow
5 they smell that advantage they
absolutely nailed you they will hit you
hard and you just won't know what's
happened
the snowball tear he comes out they are
one of the strongest noble teams known
to man at this point the outcome was
clear favoring Moscow 5 in more ways
than one
but CLG EU were unwavering in their
patience and waited for the perfect
moment to turn the tables straight away
you can see the poor ice coming down as
well beauty comes out Darian mansions to
pick up one kill there all she was
canceled the ulti was not quite run
through Kenta it's gonna get taken out
as well and CLG absolutely coming out on
top of this one it has to be a 2 for 1
gauge is gonna go down he will get pops
now time it breaks also getting another
wall goes across blocks of all beautiful
play
will is blown the girls go steeper
because you don't get the double kill
their training is really pop
absolutely destroyed engine dies from
Target while the gonna diverge or getcha
then that kick comes out on towards get
ahead foot sorry for price Holly she's
now the target that is Ricky picking up
another key diamond break trying to get
away from this one yellow beets just a
jump on his face any minute now
there we go the shutdown comes in the
ACE comes out from Co t this is insane
the nexus story has already gone down
the second nexus story has come down and
CLG pull off the biggies come back
though we've ever seen and so CLG EU had
overcome seemingly insurmountable odds
to beat their biggest rivals snatching
victory for the unlikeliest of results
topping off our list is arguably the
greatest dota game ever played
it's Iggy's impossible come back against
mega creeps in the ti6 upper bracket
semi-finals now EG were favourites going
into the tournament as defending
champions so it was a shock when they
fell so far behind to eHome in the early
stages of Game one making his move
forward he's got that whirling death one
more to do it low
Saturday's first blood for fan
has another poisonous up the three
stacks but doesn't look like it's gonna
be enough a second till go in the way of
eHome I don't think it's gonna go well
for us he hope he took so much on that
whirling death and now but slowly taken
away the shadow word will Bennett alive
a third kill for a home as the game wore
on the deficit grew larger and it seemed
like eg were doomed
eHome pushed into E G's base and got the
barracks all of them no one had ever
come back against mega creeps on the TI
main stage but the defending champs were
resilient but here comes that all these
flash bounce around their shattered even
hoping to be able to go into time
[Applause]
[Applause]
and he's trying to get PPD but evil
geniuses pull top elected they're
holding those events here
[Applause]
[Music]
the tier boards being beaten on it began
[Applause]
possible
Iggy's come back against impossible odds
wasn't pretty but for the North American
home crowd and dota fans everywhere it
was beautiful
all right well there you have it the top
ten greatest comebacks of all time now
you may have noticed that dota came in
at number one if you'd like to see that
happen more often make sure to sub to
the channel and let me know in the
comments as the scores resident dota
head it keeps me armored and mana regen
see you next time dude why am I not on
this list I haven't done talked to any
in like a month and we shot it like two
months ago
this this right here this is the
greatest comeback in eSports history
where could I be
[Laughter]
[Music]